take off your FBI hats for a second and
just be regular good old Americans all
right we're talking about January 6 for
a second how do you process what
actually happened that day and what do
you think the FBI did right and what do
you think they definitely did wrong what
do you think
I think that uh it was not this wasn't a
perfect puzzle piece that went all
together I think that President Trump's
ascendancy brought a lot of people who
were novice and new to the political
process he got a lot of people very
excited voting for the first time
engaged in politics couple that with the
2020 shutdowns where essentially
politics became sports and entertainment
for a lot of people and I think that
there was genuine belief on a lot by a
lot of people that they were going there
to exercise their first amendment and
that they had the opportunity to pause
this transfer of power this
certification of the election because
they just wanted to stop the state